welcome to another GS news update I'm
Justin hey Walt EA has recently
confirmed that han Solo Princess Leia
and Emperor Palpatine are going to be
confirmed playable characters and Star
Wars Battlefront according to lead
designer Jamie keen han Solo is similar
to a rebel trooper but with a greatly
boosted Arsenal offensive output damage
and mobility that's what this guy's
about his abilities include rapid fire
which lets you fire his blaster as fast
as you can pull the trigger lucky shot a
build up and release power that does
major damage to enemies and vehicles and
can also break Vader's block and
shoulder charge kien explains Leia is a
character that succeeds through her
fearless strategic mind we can all
remember moments when her quick thinking
blaster fire helped the rebels out of
trouble players fun and close to her
will spawn as Alderaan honor guards her
abilities include trooper Bane which
kills stormtroopers in one hit and
significantly damages villains enhanced
squad shield an improved version of the
squad shield power card that leah can
shoot out of & Supply Drop which drops a
variety of power-ups for rebel fighters
for Emperor Palpatine Keene says we
wanted him to be very mobile but also
about deception and fooling people that
he's fragile and weak as you've seen in
the original Star Wars trilogy Palpatine
pretends to be a weak old man when he in
fact is extremely powerful his abilities
include force lightning which does
significant damage to any one close by
Chain Lightning which does major damage
to enemies in all directions Imperial
resources which give power-ups to
teammates and health boost to other
villains and force dash which lets you
move around quickly layup Palpatine and
solo join the existing roster of
characters which already includes Darth
Vader Luke Skywalker and Boba Fett but
there could be some more announcements
in the future personally I'm holding out
for Jabba the Hutt
you